If there are 6 people
in your family,
and each person drinks 4/5 of
a gallon of milk each month,
between what two whole numbers
is the number of gallons
of milk your family
will drink each month?
So let's think about
this a little bit.
So I've got my milk gallon
here for inspiration.
So there's 6 people
in my family,
or in your family, whoever's
family we're talking about.
And each of them drink
4/5 of a gallon per month.
So we're going to go 6
times 4/5, or 4/5 times 6.
Now, what is this
going to be equal to?
Well, there are several ways
we could think about this.
One, we can express
6 as a fraction.
We could say that this is the
same thing as 6/1 times 4/5.
And you multiply the numerators.
You multiply the denominators.
6 times 4 is 24.
And 1 times 5 is 5.
So 24/5 gallons are going
to be drunk every month.
And this is the same
thing-- let's see,
5 goes into 20 evenly
and has a remainder of 4.
So we could write this
as 20/5 plus 4/5 5--
let me move over a little
bit so I don't run out
of space, which
is the same thing.
This is 4.
So this is 4 and 4/5.
So that's one way
to think about it.
The other way, you could
think of this as 4/5 times 6,
which is the same thing
as 4/5 plus 4/5 plus 4/5--
I think you get the idea--
plus 4/5 plus 4/5 plus 4/5.
We took literally six 4/5's
and added them together.
And what's this
going to be equal to?
Well, this is going to
be 4 plus 4 plus 4 plus 4
plus 4 plus 4 over 5.
This is how many 1/5's we have.
Well, this is 6
times 4, or you could
say 4 times 6, over 5,
which is equal to 24 over 5,
which we've already
figured out is 4 and 4/5.
So either way,
we're going to drink
4 and 4/5 gallons per month.
Now let's try to answer
the actual question.
Between what two whole numbers?
Well, between 4 and
5 gallons a month.
4 and 4/5 is right
in between 4 and 5.
We got it right.